hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem k closest points
to the origin so let's take a look at
this example and you can't really see it
well but they have a couple points so
there's one point over here and there's
one point over here so we have a list of
points right we could have a bunch more
points right anywhere on this
two-dimensional grid we have an x-axis
and a y-axis so each point is
represented by a pair of values this
point is 1
3 this point is negative 2
right and so we can have a bunch more
points and we want to return from the
entire list of points we want to return
the k closest points to the origin now
the origin is the
center which is zero zero right so which
of these points is the closest to the
origin and in this case we have k equals
one so from these two points we just
want to return the single point that is
the closest to the origin and we're
guaranteed that the solution is going to
be unique so there's never going to be a
tie or anything like that but it could
be you know
in this case we have k is 1 it could be
k is 2 k is 3 or something if we had a
bunch more points so we just want to
figure out efficiently what are the k
closest points to the origin now the
first thing is how do we know how far
any given point actually is from the
origin you know you might remember from
your you know high school math class or
in this case they actually tell us the
actual formula which does make things a
little bit easy so it's basically taking
the x difference right so in this case
for this point the x difference is going
to be 1 minus 0 plus the y difference in
this case the y difference is going to
be three minus zero and each of these is
going to be squared because you know
that's kind of how it works a squared
plus b squared equals c squared this is
the formula we're using so if we want to
find c which is going to be the actual
distance we'll take a squared plus b
squared and then take the square root of
the entire thing to actually find c so
you know finding the distance we can do
that a squared plus b squared taking the
square root but in this case we actually
aren't required to find the square root
because we're not actually trying to
return the distance we're just trying to
determine which point is the closest so
you know for example let's say we had
something like this that totaled up to
five right and we had another one that
totaled up to 4. if we take the square
root of 2 or 4 that's going to give us 2
if we take the square root of 5 is going
to give us 2 point you know something
something so we're not required to take
the square root because we just want to
be able to compare which one is greater
right obviously if 5 is greater than 4
we know that that the square root of 5
is also going to be greater than 4 so
we're not technically required to
actually take that square root and i
don't know why i'm making this such a
big point it's just that it's kind of
easier to code it up then if we don't
actually have to take the square root we
just take the absolute difference
between the x
square it the difference between the y
square it and then add them together
that will be enough for us to compare
two points and to figure out which one
of them is actually closer to the origin
so once you have that down how can we
actually find the k closest points we're
not just finding the single closest
point that would be easy but we're
trying to find k of the closest points
well the the easiest and simplest idea
that you might think of is just sorting
right so if we have a list of size n and
for each one of these points we you know
compute this
take the x difference y difference
square it right and use that value to
sort the entire list of points the time
complexity of that is going to be n
log n because we're sorting the entire
list and then once we have that right
like let's say we had
what you know three values or something
we just wanted the first two which is k
and then we can just iterate through the
list and find k so the k is not really
going to change the time complexity the
time complexity is going to depend on
the n log n sorting but since we're only
looking for k points right we don't
actually need to sort the entire thing
we just need the k closest points so
actually this problem can be
reduced or slightly simplified if you
use a min heap and that's going to be
the solution i'm showing you if you
you know if you already know how to use
a min heap you can probably skip to the
coding portion or you know solve this
problem yourself a min heap is a good
way to solve this problem but i'm going
to analyze it for you right now so let's
still take the simplified example so
like i said the first thing we're going
to do for every point so we have the
point 1
3 and we want to know the distance
between it so we can say okay 1 squared
plus 3 squared which is going to give us
10 so this is you know the distance
actually isn't 10 but that's going to be
the value we use to compare we're not
going to take the square root because we
actually don't need to the other one
negative 2
positive 2 is going to be 2 squared plus
2 plus negative 2 squared which is you
know just going to be 2 squared as well
so
taking both of these together is going
to be
a distance of 8 so
the next thing we're going to do is
take these right notice how we put the
distance as the first value because when
we put this in a min heap we want this
to be the value that we order it by so
we're going to take this and we're going
to run the function heapify which is not
n log n heapify is actually a linear
time algorithm so it'll basically take
all of these put them into a heap in o
of end time so now
you know let's say that all of these are
in our min heap what are we going to do
we want to pop from this heap k times
because we want every time we pop we
want to pop the closest one which is in
this case going to be this point right
and of course k in our example is only
one but obviously this solution could be
generalized to if k was two three or
bigger right so in this case how many
times are we gonna pop from the min heap
obviously k times we only need to find
the k closest points and what's the
operation for for popping from a heap
it's going to be log the size of the
heap which is worst case going to be n
so this time complexity is actually
going to be a little bit better it's
going to be k log n that's why a min
heap solution is slightly more efficient
because if k is relatively small it's
going to be a lot better than something
like n log n right this is much smaller
this is much faster so that's kind of
the idea at this point you probably know
how to code it up but you know just to
finish the example k is one we pop from
this one time are we gonna pop this one
or this one obviously this one has a
smaller distance so we pop this one and
then we take it append it to our result
and we we only append the coordinates
the coordinates were negative two
positive two right we don't actually
have to append the distance or anything
so this will be added to our result and
then we're going to return that result
right we only need to pop once
and we can return that you can see up in
the result over here at the top that's
exactly what they did they just returned
a list of one point
so that is the main solution now we can
go ahead and code it up so now let's
actually code it up and like i said
we're going to be using a min heap so
initially a min heap is just an array or
a list in python so what we want to do
is we actually want to go through every
pair of points every x y in the input
list points and we want to go ahead and
actually compute the distance so how can
we compute the distance for every point
well it's pretty much just going to be x
squared plus y squared right so we can
take x in python you can take x to the
power of 2 like this plus y to the power
of 2 like this and add those together we
just won't take the square root because
we're lazy and we know that we don't
actually need to take the square root so
then to our points or rather to our min
heap we can append to it this uh point
that we just calculated right so we'll
append the three values we talked about
the distance is gonna go first because
that's the key value for our min heap
python will use that the first value by
default and we're going to also append
the coordinates of this point as well
and now that we have all those points in
a list obviously that this operation was
a linear time operation now we're also
going to do a linear time operation in
python we can turn that list into a heap
like this
heapq.heapify that list so it'll reorder
the list to make sure that it is in the
structure of a heap and we also want to
have a list for the result right we're
going to pop k times so while k is
greater than zero we're going to keep
popping from our min heap we're gonna
say heap q dot heap
pop from the min heap and whatever value
is popped we're gonna append it to the
result just like this but actually i
just realized we're actually popping
three values from it so before we append
it let's get the three values we're
popping the distance the the
x-coordinate and the y-coordinate from
the min heap and once we pop those three
values to our result itself we're only
appending two values the coordinates the
x and y coordinates and we're gonna do
that k time so let's make sure to
decrement our k value and so once we've
popped from it k times we can go ahead
and return the result that we just
created and as you can see the solution
works and it is pretty efficient i think
a sorting approach would be about as
efficient but this is slightly better in
some cases so i hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching